Pup Magical girl just
Corsmere There's a strange feeling when you reply in front of me It's because of the magic girl's two-eyed
5-person induction field If you
don't reveal your identity, you won't match your appearance before transformation
Know your identity  But it feels a little strange I
think my magic is because he's too strong Okay, are you
ready to
go now?
I'm the point man.
No matter how many times I look at it, it's amazing destructive power To be
precise, it's impossible to penetrate with magic power
From the table with the door and the wall iron plate installed,
it penetrates even the bulletproof vest for nij project type 3 It's
numb, it's gone